Le système architectural
doit donc être à la fois compact, compressible et léger
et je crois que j'en ai un juste là.
C'est très compact
et très léger.
Et en fait,
en voilà un que j'ai fait tout à l'heure.
Cet objet présente un problème :
les éléments gonflables
sont assez fragiles.
Ils doivent être protégés,
en particulier lorsque vous voyagez vers un environnement hostile comme la Lune.
Considérez les choses de cette façon.
La différence de température sur une base lunaire
peut atteindre 200 degrés.
D'un côté de la base, il pourrait faire 100 degrés Celsius
et de l'autre côté, il pourrait faire -100 degrés.
Nous devons nous protéger de ces variations extrêmes.
La Lune ne possède aucun champ magnétique
ce qui veut dire que toute radiation — radiation solaire, radiation cosmique —
touchera la surface.
Nous devons aussi nous protéger, ainsi que les astronautes, des radiations.
Et troisièmement,
et certainement pas le dernier,
la Lune n'a pas d'atmosphère,
ce qui veut dire que les météorites se dirigeant vers la Lune
ne seront pas désintégrées et percuteront la surface.
C'est pour ça que la Lune est pleine de cratères.
Encore, nous devons protéger les astronautes de ça.
De quel type de structure avons-nous besoin ?
La meilleure solution serait vraiment une grotte.
Une grotte a une masse importante et nous en avons besoin.
Nous avons besoin de masse pour nous protéger des températures,
des radiations
et des météorites.
Voici la solution que nous avons trouvée.
Nous avons la partie bleue, comme vous pouvez le voir.
C'est l'élément gonflable de notre base lunaire.
Elle offre beaucoup d'espace de vie et d'espace de laboratoire.
Elle est attachée à un cylindre
qui possède toutes les structures de support,
tous les systèmes de survie ainsi que le sas.
Au-dessus, nous avons une structure, cette structure en dôme
qui nous protège,
qui a une masse importante.
Où allons-nous trouver ces matières premières ?
Allons-nous amener du béton depuis la Terre sur la Lune ?
Bien sûr que non, parce que c'est bien trop lourd.
C'est trop cher.
Nous allons utiliser des matières premières locales.
Nous faisons aussi appel aux matières premières locales sur Terre.
Peu importe le pays, on cherche toujours les matières premières locales.
Le problème avec la Lune, c'est de trouver ces matières premières.
Il n'y en a pas tant que ça.
En fait, nous en avons trouvé une.
C'est la poussière de lune,
ou, de son beau nom scientifique, régolithe, le régolithe lunaire.
Ce qui est génial, c'est qu'il y en a partout.
La surface en est recouverte.
Il y en a des couches de 20 centimètres à quelques mètres partout.
Mais comment allons-nous construire avec ?
Nous allons utiliser une imprimante 3D.
Si je vous demande ce qu'est une imprimante 3D,
vous pensez probablement à quelque chose de cette taille
qui imprimerait des choses de cette taille.
Je ne vais bien sûr pas amener une énorme imprimante 3D sur la Lune
pour imprimer ma base lunaire.
Je vais utiliser un appareil beaucoup plus petit, comme celui-ci.
C'est un petit engin, un petit robot
avec une petite pelle.
Il amène le régolithe au dôme
puis étale une fine couche de régolithe,
et enfin vous avez le robot qui solidifiera le tout,
couche par couche,
jusqu'à la création, après quelques mois,
de la base complète.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué
que nous imprimons une structure assez particulière
et j'en ai un exemple ici.
Nous appelons ceci une structure en mousse à alvéoles fermées.
Elle paraît assez naturelle.
Nous l'utilisons en tant qu'élément de cette structure de coque
parce que nous avons besoin de solidifier seulement certains endroits,
ce qui signifie que nous pouvons amener moins d'élément liant de la Terre,
ce qui est beaucoup plus léger.
Maintenant —
cette approche consistant à créer quelque chose
et à le recouvrir d'un dôme protecteur,
nous l'avons aussi appliquée à notre projet pour Mars.
Vous pouvez le voir ici, trois dômes.
Et vous voyez les imprimantes imprimer ces structures en dôme.
Il y a une grande différence entre Mars et la Lune
et je vais vous l'expliquer.
Cette figure vous montre à l'échelle
la taille de la Terre et de la Lune ainsi que la distance réelle,
400 000 kilomètres environ.
Si nous allons ensuite sur Mars,
la distance entre Mars et la Terre —
et cette image ici
a été prise par Curiosity, le robot sur Mars, regardant la Terre.
Vous voyez cette petite tache là, c'est la Terre,
à 400 millions de kilomètres.
Le problème avec cette distance
c'est qu'elle fait mille fois la distance entre la Terre et la Lune,
mais on n'a pas de contact radio en direct avec, par exemple, le robot Curiosity.
Je ne peux donc pas le télécommander depuis la Terre.
Je ne peux pas dire : « Eh, robot martien, va à gauche »
parce que ce signal mettrait 20 minutes à atteindre Mars.
Le robot irait peut-être à gauche
et il faudrait encore 20 minutes avant qu'il puisse me dire :
« Au fait, je suis allé à gauche. »
Donc la distance,
donc les robots
vont devoir travailler de façon autonome.
Le seul problème,
c'est que les missions sur Mars sont très risquées.
On l'a constaté il y a seulement quelques semaines.
Et si la moitié de la mission n'atteint pas Mars,
que faisons-nous ?
Au lieu de ne construire qu'un ou deux robots
comme on l'a fait sur la Lune,
nous allons en construire des centaines.
C'est un peu comme une termitière, vous savez ?
Si je retire la moitié de la colonie de termites,
elles pourront toujours construire la termitière.
Ça prendra juste un peu plus longtemps.
C'est pareil ici.
Si la moitié de nos robots n'arrivent pas sur Mars,
ça prendra plus de temps mais ils pourront toujours le faire.
Ici, nous avons même trois robots différents.
À l'arrière, vous voyez l'excavateur.
Il est très bon à creuser le régolithe.
Puis nous avons le transporteur,
très bon à ramasser le régolithe et à l'amener à la structure.
Les derniers, avec les petites jambes, ils n'ont pas vraiment besoin de bouger.
Leur tâche est d'aller se mettre sur une couche de régolithe,
de la passer sous des micro-ondes
et couche par couche, de créer cette structure.
Maintenant —
nous voulons tester ce processus
donc nous sommes partis en road-trip
et nous avons créé notre propre essaim de robots.
Et voilà.
Nous en avons construit dix. C'est un petit essaim.
Nous avons pris six tonnes de sable
et nous avons testé comment ces petits robots
seraient capables de déplacer du sable,
du sable terrien dans ce cas.
Et ils n'étaient pas télécommandés, d'accord ?
Personne ne leur a dit d'aller à gauche, à droite,
ni leur a donné un chemin prédéfini.
Non, ils avaient une tâche à accomplir :
déplacer du sable de cet endroit à cet endroit.
S'ils se trouvaient face à un obstacle, comme un caillou,
ils devaient se tirer d'affaire tout seuls.
S'ils rencontraient un autre robot,
ils devaient pouvoir prendre des décisions.
Même si la moitié d'entre eux tombaient, si leurs batteries lâchaient,
ils devaient toujours être capables d'accomplir cette tâche.
J'ai parlé de la redondance.
Mais ce n'est pas que pour les robots.
C'est aussi avec les habitats.
Pour le projet sur Mars, nous avons décidé de faire trois dômes,
parce que si l'un d'entre eux n'arrivait pas à destination,
les deux autres pourraient toujours former une base
parce qu'en effet, chacun des dômes
possède un système de survie intégré dans le sol,
pour qu'ils puissent fonctionner séparément.
D'une façon, vous pensez peut-être que c'est assez fou.
Pourquoi, en tant qu'architecte, vous intéresseriez-vous à l'espace ?
Parce que c'est un domaine tellement technique.
Je suis réellement convaincu
que d'un point de vue créatif ou d'un point de vue de design,
vous pouvez résoudre des problèmes très difficiles et très contraignants.
Je crois vraiment qu'il y a une place pour le design et l'architecture
dans des projets tels que l'habitation interplanétaire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)